[موسيقى]
المتظاهرون خارج
شركة الكهرباء اللبنانية يشعلون الشموع
ويلعنون أزهار الظلام على المكان الذي
أطلق فيه علي محمد هيك البالغ من العمر 61 عامًا النار وقتل
نفسه على
ما يبدو في حالة يأس حيث
يتدهور الاقتصاد اللبناني.
مظاهرة تجمعت بعد أن
قتل علي نفسه بجذوره العارية ذات
يوم في شارع الحمارة الذي كان رائجًا ،
اتخذ الآخرون نهجًا أكثر عنفًا للتعبير
عن غضبهم من مستويات المعيشة
ما تراه الآن ليس أزمة ،
إنه انهيار اقتصادي ديما كرين
يتبع لبنان.  اندلعت مفاوضات غير مثمرة إلى حد بعيد
مع
صندوق النقد الدولي بشأن خطة الإنقاذ في أكتوبر / تشرين الأول من
العام الماضي ، حيث اندلعت الاحتجاجات في جميع أنحاء البلاد حيث
بدأ القطاع المصرفي اللبناني في
الانهيار ، وكانت تستند إلى ما
وصفه الاقتصاديون بخطة بونزي حيث
عرضت البنوك اللبنانية معدلات فائدة مرتفعة للغاية
على المغتربين اللبنانيين في الغالب.
المودعين ثم استخدموا تلك الودائع
لتمويل الحكومة المتضخمة
عجز nt هو انهيار لنموذج كامل ،
إنه انهيار لنموذج
تراكمت عليه الخسائر لمدة ثلاثة عقود
، والآن تتحمل
الغالبية العبء الأكبر من هذا الانهيار
مقابل 1٪ التي استخدمت
وحققت مبلغًا لا نهائيًا  من
الدولارات من هذا النظام في
الأشهر الأخيرة ، ارتفعت الأسعار والبطالة بشكل
كبير ، حيث فقد القائد
الكثير من قيمتها ، اقتلهم الآن
شاركوا الخلايا الليمفاوية للعيش طوال اليوم الذي
كنت أعمل فيه ولم أكسب سوى تسعة
آلاف ليرة تقول هذه التاكسي  السائق في
هذا اليوم الذي كان يقارب الدولار
قبل عام كان ستة جزارين
يؤذون الفوشيه لا يستطيعون تغطية نفقاتهم
، أنا مغلق بلا مبيعات ، كل ما
يقوله من الأكياس البلاستيكية إلى الورق
الذي يلفه في الاجتماع  أصبحت
باهظة الثمن
عبر متاجر بيروت
وأوقفنا العمل مع الكهرباء
لمدة يومين كان لدينا أكثر من 20
ساعة من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي يوميًا وكان ذلك
قاسيًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا
لإبقاء الأضواء مضاءة في Maine State H في بيروت.
المستشفى هو مجرد شيء واحد
يحافظ على المخرج د.  فلوريس حبلة في
الليل تتزايد حالات kovat 19 هنا
بينما تتبخر الموارد إذا أصبح
الوضع أكثر صعوبة
والمظاهر في الوقت الحالي هو أنه
قد يصبح الأمر أكثر صعوبة سواء كنا
سنستمر في إيجاد
الحلول وإجابتي في هذه اللحظة هي  لا
أعرف بالنسبة لأولئك الذين وصلوا إلى
الحضيض ، فإن القمامة هي الملاذ الأخير
في لبنان ، ولا أحد لديه إجابات ،
فقد كنا سي إن إن